[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL PICCUIRRO: We chose
Google Cloud platform because
it is a great tool that allows
us to build solutions very
quickly and deploy them
somewhere that can scale to
whatever we need.
STEFAN HAUK: When we release a
new game, it usually becomes
immediately very popular.
We have 263 million monthly
players at the end of last
year who are already
playing our games.
And when we tell them that
there's a new game, they all
come to it and try to play it.
So we need a lot of computer
power from the start.
KARS VELING: And App Engine
allows us to create new
things, focus on the new things,
and only need 1% or so
to focus on maintenance because
App Engine takes care
of a lot of stuff.
I think basically it's a
worry-free platform for us.
CHANDRA KRINTZ: My favorite
feature of Google Cloud
Platform is the App Engine Data
Store, because it makes
it really easy to
do large-scale
data analytics across.
ROBERT KLUIN: So for example,
if we're developing on App
Engine and we have services
such as Memcache readily
available to us without needing
to do a tremendous
amount of configuration
or work.
ALAGAPPAN ALS: We chose Google
App Engine because we wanted
to focus on developing features
that are facing
millions of users rather than
having to focus on hardware,
service scaling, and dealing
with hardware failure and
other such stuff.
MOMCHIL KYURKCHIEV: We're
a young company,
less than a year old.
And so for us, building
a minimum viable
product is very important.
So we start with something
small, and then we upgrade it.
And I think App Engine
is designed exactly
for this use case.
So you start with something
small, you get it working.
And then as you need more
complex infrastructure, more
hardware, you can add it on,
more features, of course.
But that's ideal for
our use case.
DEREK STEVENSON: We chose Google
Cloud Platform in large
part for our analytic needs.
So we looked at a variety of
options and settled on a
BigQuery as a key enabler for
some of our analytic projects.
MATT MCCLURE: With Google
Cloud Platform's network
performance, we're able to
provide really low-latency
live streams, which is really
important to our customers
that are using our
live service.
MICHAEL PICCUIRRO: Things that
would have taken years to
build are going to take
weeks or months.
And we'll be able to produce
these richer experiences,
these more effective experiences
for our clients
than we were able
to do before.
STEFAN HAUK: My advice would be
that you should try to keep
your team small, focus on what
you can do best, and leave the
operational aspects to the
people who know how to do
that, in that case, the Google
Cloud Platform team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]